My Hope Is that you create another life
and you don't know his dating
status unless he invites you in or
unless he's bringing somebody else home
around your kids and then you need to
know that but I want you to separate
your life from his you need time to heal
and you need time
to this whole thing just sounds like a
mess and I would pull myself out of it
and I would focus my time on my kids and
on my kids safety and he's going to go
do what he's going to go do but I wish
you the best and I wish that you begin
let let there be a period at the end of
this
sentence and go on about healing and
creating your new life because you're
worth peace and right now you don't have
that